hello there reject nation we're gonna
watch brooklyn nine nine season three
episode something or another ladies and
ladies if you like to watch a
full-length reaction watch along sync up
with the time code that's at our patreon
page thanks to all became super just
checking out everything over there but
if you can't do that leave a like that
would mean a lot and leave a comment too
that would also mean a lot and i want to
say thank you to everyone who leaves
comments about our discussions after the
reactions i know they're a little bit
off the wall
however we're gonna start taking it more
serious afterwards and no more fun and
games around here lastly the boys at
prepper you guys have huge longs let's
do this
[Music]
prepare to start clapping because i just
made a major drug bust talking about
four kilos of cocaine 200 000 cash and
my new partner hey mrs doubt spider aka
joe spiden aka tarantula bassett aka spy
dermot mulroney are you out of your mind
they were gonna throw them away but i
couldn't let them do that to my furry
little oh he's actually really scary up
close
terry hates creepy crawlers seriously
i'm not going to your apartment if that
thing is there all right fine then he'll
just live here and help me solve crimes
get used to him everyone cause me and
this spider are partners for life
crawlers
he can fly can tarantulas fly jake you
better find that spider and i'm not
coming back here until you do
dude sarge
i think i found it
why are you looking at me like that
it's on my head
no
no it's always the fear that the spider
no it's gonna the ability to just hop up
anywhere regardless of the laws of
physics the show isn't a comedy it's a
nightmare
goddamn trap horror show i'm drowning my
sorrows in octopus balls i've been
online dating it's a total disaster i've
only had one match and it was a pretty
obvious catfish situation my name's
jennifer you gave me social security oh
jennifer
out of all the identities he could have
stolen he chose yours and you want to
know why because i posted my annual
income because you posted your annual
income you [ __ ] excuse me is that
takoyaki huh oh i love that place the
chef lets me take octopus hearts home
for my dogs oh lucky how many dogs you
have three that's how many i have oh how
do you keep them off the bed i gave up i
sleep on the floor me too
it's better for your back
is it nice
what an idiot what are you doing she's
walking away i got nervous she needs
octopus balls and she sleeps on the
floor she's the perfect woman god
sorry i was aiming at somebody else but
now that i have your attention charles
you're just aiming at a terrible
criminal he probably
[Laughter]
it's no secret the nypd has an image
problem all the headlines are about the
bad cops but they're good cops too and i
want to put up posters that showcase
some of our best i'd like you to be on
the first one whoa
[Music]
putting up a bunch of photos of smiling
cops isn't gonna change how people feel
about us i think this campaign is very
promising santiago what's your take oh
right let's hear an unbiased opinion
from your straight-up swim fan
i think it's a great idea sir
well you can count me out i will not
pose for your posters i didn't ask you
and you're not a police officer yeah
i'm out why is she dressed like nurse
ratchet
nurse ratchet going to play tennis they
ate my moose tracks ice cream
that's funny i wouldn't think you like
moose tracks my boyfriend marcus
introduced me to it uh did you see them
take the ice cream no we need hard proof
so let's get it
step one put a delicious pie in the
fridge and cover it with poison that's
step one
step two tell their widows they were
thieves
[Laughter]
she is amazing her palette is wide and
deep gross at one point when she wasn't
looking i snuck a whiff of her hair
sounds good boy did you get her number
oh we lost track of time she had to go
back into court when she's done
i'm gonna ask her out oh okay
going straight from here to the spa
couple's massage okay seems a little
intense but given how your other
weirdness lined up i say go for it
oh there she comes whoa okay how do i
look you look great she's decremental
isn't she she must be she's going to
jail i know we just met and i don't want
to be too forward charles sometimes you
just get a feeling about a person
charles i got that feeling about you i
like you charles look down tonight oh
shoot they just gave me 10 years in
prison
[Music]
she didn't say
no you're gonna hold out for a decade i
talked to genevieve's lawyer he's a
total disaster i have a couple questions
about a beautiful client of yours
genevieve mirren carter she got hit by a
tow truck and sued the driver no she was
accused of insurance fraud oh good cause
i blew that tow truck case
straight i forgot to go to court
stolen paintings in her house but she
said she didn't know how it ended up
there she's being set up framed art joke
look i i know you think my judgment's
clouded because i like her a little bit
you doodled your wedding invitation no
that's our joint tombstone my mistake
something's off about the case i trust
your gut
let's go free an innocent woman nice
follow that hunch you and me get my lady
off together hmm nice i think about that
too
title of our sex [ __ ]
ames i want to say you look great thank
you you didn't let me finish dot dot dot
for you
this isn't going to work and all i'm
saying is a if not the boss here is if
you're not going to support me you can
leave fine look what i found in
hitchcock and scully's trash can ice
cream spoons
[Laughter]
why was this in your trash i don't even
think it's ice cream it's probably
medicine you know i'm on lots of
medicines rosa i'm sick all over
now then is there anybody you can think
of besides yourself that has access to
the gallery after hours no just me and
the vault is only accessible through
fingerprint id does charles have a
girlfriend i just saw her mouth my name
what did she say is she asking if i'm
circumcised
can you think of anyone that might be
trying to set you up maybe my
ex-boyfriend nick he's an artist a
terrible one dirtbag x oh that was my
theory remember tell her it was my
theory okay wait give me a second i want
to look smart when you say it okay
uh hey jenna
apparently mr butthead just bought a
brand new gallery in dumbo to showcase
his art which is weird because genevieve
said he was always in debt looks like
somebody just came in to a ton of money
oh and you think she's gonna want to get
back together with him now that he's
rich
no she's definitely got the cash from
selling the stolen art your hunch was
right my hunch my hunch my lovely casey
hunch clenchie sing with me that's not
gonna happen i will literally never what
you gonna do with laughs
solve this case solve this case right in
your face we should probably leave this
prison yep
[Laughter]
okay here's my cover my name is sherwin
lamont sculptor painter full-time
barista but once i sell my first piece
part-time barista oh nice
oh wow i love your outfit i'm an artist
so i get that it's more than just tight
nick likes to coat women in latex he's
fascinated by the idea of the human
chrysalis and society's pupation human
chrysalis and whatnot
yeah you know what not
it's a whatnot
it's a what-not
very cool
anyhow i'm a fellow artist named sherwin
i'm donald hoberman sites i wear glasses
i was wondering how'd you get your own
gallery it must be really expensive
art's not about the money man
totally it's more about the
other things
right on right on it's called
genevieve416.
what's that all about well april 16th
was day my ex genevieve and i covered
ourselves with paint and made love on
that campus for 24 hours straight that's
pretty pathetic dude you seem pretty
obsessed with genevieve huh no
you were robbing genevieve's gallery you
framed her and i should arrest you right
now what are you cops what no we're
artists get out of here fine but we're
taking this because you don't deserve
that memory that penny's 95 000. i don't
want it anyway your penis was on it
embarrassing
yep it's definitely ice cream newer i'm
lactose intolerant me too you're lying
have you ever seen us eat dairy you know
no one can bear to watch you eat jack
and
check
link was pretty defensive
yeah and he's a terrible artist all he
does is have sex on canvases any fourth
grader could do that
but
they shouldn't
he would never set up genevieve he's
still in love with her he keeps boxes of
her old stuff lying around you wouldn't
happen to know where he was on july 21st
would you he lived in a cage on the
street and he never left it where in
this cage did he go to the bathroom
bucket okay gross have a good night and
where were you that day latex lady
people drew on every single poster they
put double horns
target on my face this one says die pig
wow
i think gina was right about the
campaign sir
i'm surprised she hasn't marched in here
to say i told you so she wouldn't do
that you're right amy
he sat in a cage for a month yeah the
bucket checks out
this is insane anything is art here
watch this uh a statue of jesus made out
of cigarette butts boom i'm a
millionaire that's actually pretty good
i know and i could call it holy smokes
do it that's crazy you can't just become
an artist out of nowhere jake what
[Laughter]
it's a receipt for a storage unit that
she didn't tell anyone about
it's probably nothing yeah yeah yeah i'm
sure it's nothing it's totally nothing
it's a bunch of stolen art
damn it
damn it i'm resigned to my life of
solitude just me and my five dogs wait i
thought you only had three dogs i just
adopted two online right now
no this pit bull hates kids that's fine
i'll never have any add to cart
add to cart there are plenty of women
out there strong beautiful smart women
how about her she's very beautiful
my look she's probably your car thief
just booked her for elder abuse
eldridge that's nice
paint and make love for 25 hours one
more hour than her and nick boyle you
would hate that your little hummingbird
heart would explode i wish i didn't have
a heart
oh there was some backlash to the poster
campaign yes i'm the nostradamus of your
shame
i should have been open to criticism as
this department should be open to
criticism [ __ ] that i'm replacing these
with
these hmm
my email address is at the bottom and i
intend to respond to every message i
receive oh boy careful
once again my advice has like saved the
city
i can't prove you took my mood strikes
so i shouldn't have yelled at you i'm
impressed we want to make it up to you
you got your pizza only one pizza for
both of us the dairy
oh my god that was an obvious setup you
morons
you're eating cheese you're lying about
being lactose intolerant no we weren't
some things are just delicious enough to
suffer the consequences i'm diabetic but
i still eat sugar out of the bag
oh yeah
yeah we hate it
and we're eating your pizza so who's the
[ __ ] now
booze dummy
oh
shack up in there
getting in a little late there this
morning boyle where you been cursing out
my own shadow for hanging out with a
loser like me
that's nick's assistant why is she here
check out the date on this receipt from
the storage locker with the stolen art 4
16. exactly she couldn't have rented it
because she was busy
getting busy oh i mean i'm not happy
that she was having sex with another man
but i'm okay with it if that's what gets
her off
yeah she used one of those latex casts
of genevieve's hand to get the
fingerprint so she could break into the
gallery wow i can't believe you kept
working the case even after i gave up go
get your girlfriend out of prison oh
come on thanks man next time you see me
i'm gonna be all out of orgasms no you
can't say that while you're hugging
someone
all out
do it boy i have so many orgasms oh
they're pent up they're just bursting to
get out no one will touch me
gosh
not even by accident
that's the only time when it happens
switch your bed sheets out
dude oh my goodness gracious me i think
we should dress up in in body tight
latex from now on i mean look at how
sharp that girl who turned out to be a
criminal was looking that whole criminal
i'm a criminal yeah man that's all i
could think about this whole episode was
like eminem boy
i wonder what would happen if he wrote
an entire episode of brooklyn 99 all in
rhyme
you know yes andy doesn't mean whatever
is said must be
deciphered into
absolutely true
that's true but greg's changed the scene
it's about epinema here to put that
theory to the test
no i think you would look good in a full
body latex i think you would accentuate
your muscles i think you would look like
a walking piece of art
john please if you were to do that don't
think i don't already know okay i'm
sorry i just wanted to make sure you
felt validated unlike
captain holt you know imagine
this tricep oh look at that look at that
that triceps
in a suit look at the line
the line the line get some shine on that
line i don't ask to see my stomach or
other parts of my body but look at this
truck look at that tricep dude don't
even try just look just do
what's this box that's
yeah dude from the start track
uh yeah it was funny man
poor boil poor boil poor boil looking
for love in all the wrong places but
maybe he looked in the right place this
time yeah that girl from 24 is funny she
should come back
yeah that's where she's from
one serious role and then every time i
see her otherwise it's always in
something comedic um
yeah
you know
like i i that would have dated someone
from prison why not mm-hmm
i get street cred imagine the friend
she'd have oh yeah plus you know she
could protect you in any scenario
maybe
depends what she went to crim to prison
for that's true well she could at least
help you out of like confined spaces
probably have a lot of advice on how to
get out of those teach me how to shank a
man shank yeah not only how to shank but
how to build the shank
you know best shank building practices
a lot i've still have my cub scouts
pocket knife
that has not come in handy in a fight
very rusty no in fact i hurt myself most
of the time it's okay whenever i've
tried to defend characters yeah yeah
and for some reason i think i can afford
another one a new one
but i have why do that when you can have
all the memories attached to it i got
two options people
get a new cub scouts knife
or
a shrink
there's no one between here no no double
fist no double fist that's what i say
yeah and uh yeah this is really sweet
touching
nothing's worse than someone who smells
though that whole thing with hitchcock
and salt
you know
they are
john's had this issue don't worry john
i'll back it up with a story about me
hello
good good job had that issue yeah eating
too much pizza and lactose intolerant
you know that's not what i'm talking
about oh yeah i know i know a story
you're actually going for you had you
had to give me back in the day in the
big brother chat about like hey bro
we're all in tight quarters and you're
getting sweaty
there's been a lot of complaints filed
about you some formal uh suggestion
boxes yeah some formal uh complaints
have been filed
one time i pooped my pants in second
grade and i spent the whole day at
school acting like i didn't
but everyone knew
that's bold though to be able to just to
like trek through and be like no
i'm coming like what was your
psychological state in that moment were
you like
i just gotta commit to this and see my
way through or were you like holding on
white knuckle you know they wouldn't let
me go to the bathroom that [ __ ] uh that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and this is taylor oh no
oh damn
gotta find her and and [ __ ] on her doors
to you baby [ __ ] my face
myself i want to make you [ __ ] yourself
and then uh but yeah we it was a bad
smelling day that's for sure
for everyone around me from getting in
the car i just told everyone i threw up
on myself
everyone knew the truth
i threw up on the back of myself even
that matt b wanted to sniff my butt he
said let me sniff your butt
turn around i was like no you're gay
yeah that's that's what's gay and
honestly it's pretty apt i don't even
call it homophobic
i think if you want to sniff my ass
you're probably great as a young man if
you're happy
to sniff my my my behind
there's a possibility sure yeah because
what's you know what's next um
so yeah
someone's taking your food that's
uncalled for classic sitcom bit classic
workplace bit yeah someone taking the
food
kids can't be stood for
don't take someone's food that's messed
up man and there's no way to prove it
ever especially if you like bring it in
these shared fridge there are rules yeah
or rules people are supposed to know
what food corresponds to who whether or
not there's a label on
um after watching what happened with the
lapd and how they had a public press
that press conference called
i'm going to see what's going on public
press conference
that's people calling the lapd
i yield my time
[Music]
what's going on buddy
she just went away for like two minutes
to get to move the laundry come on in
here
come in here
hey
look who's back you were not abandoned
you have not been she went to do the
laundry
watson it's all right have some coffee
and chill out
if you guys are at our patreon and watch
our legend of korra reactions you know
you know he's always like i want my
mommy mom mom where are you mom i can't
see you you must be dead where are you
can't i've been abandoned you're not in
my eyesight which means you've abandoned
me
are you going bud come back it's okay he
knows he's welcome now yeah that's true
anyway i'm pretty sure we reviewed the
episode we we broke the whole thing down
that boyle didn't give up he followed
his heart he was right and uh and jake
was a great wingman gina told you so
amy looks good on a poster felt bad for
her oh yeah you can't
i think it's a terrible idea
he can't be the only one answering the
emails yeah he's good new york city is
gonna be overwhelmed and the the uh
people are not gonna sugarcoat any of
that and while the police have a bad rep
new york cops are liked a lot more than
lapd um
they had some incident happen where a
lot more people became unified you know
they had an incident even though a lot
of corrupt police stories come from
1970s cop movies yeah and corrupt cops
are cool
yeah when they're doing
singing
for agreeable reasons i'm not trying to
celebrate real corrupt cops no i hate
real corrupt cops with the right kind of
dirty cop in a movie you're like [ __ ]
that's a good actor right there i wish i
was like him dirty cop of the heart of
gold
that's who you want to be
john please people are sensitive to
everything these days i
hate and love all cops
i thought it was interesting that they
at least for like the graffiti actually
did just kind of go real with it yeah
man like that seems like what people
would really write on one of these
all right guys well listen john's done
talking so i'm done talking that's the
way it works around here
everyone be quiet
back
see you guys soon